So as an entrepreneur,
as a ted and Tedx speaker,
as an award winning author,
and as someone who was named USA Today's
most connected millennial,
a lot of people ask me how I have built
my network and how I connect with
people.
And so I'll give you the high level and
then I'll go into maybe a few specifics
that you can use today to build a world
class network in record time.
At a high level,
I would think about networking in,
in three basic steps.
Step one,
which shouldn't even have to be told or
shared,
is that you should be a good person in
the whole process of building your
relationship,
which is probably easy at first.
Uh,
you,
you bump into someone at a coffee shop,
run an event.
Obviously you want to treat them with
respect.
Treat them like you would treat your mom
is,
uh,
something I was told recently that I
really like a [inaudible] shows like the
level of respect that you should have
for someone regardless of who they look
like or who they are.
Uh,
anything like that.
Just treat everyone the same,
uh,
be a good person and if you're,
if you're coming at it being a good
person instead of being selfish or
trying to win a quick contract over
someone,
I think you'll have a much better job
longterm,
uh,
in terms of building your network and as
you become a super connector,
uh,
you're going to want to be more
intentional about how you spend your
time and so they're going be more people
reaching out to you,
trying to connect with you,
and it's important to treat them
respectfully and be a good person with
maybe someone who is less knowledgeable
than you reaching out.
Even if you can't spend a lot of time
with them,
there's a respectful way to say no,
or there's a respectful way to,
uh,
talk to anyone regardless of if you end
up spending time with them or not.
So,
step one,
be a good person.
A step two is to provide value upfront.
Uh,
as you are building friendships,
connecting with people,
it's important to ask about what they
care about and what they're working on
and what's keeping them up at night.
See if you can offer connections,
are offered time or resources in order
to move their agenda forward,
and this is the same in marketing.
You want to offer a potential customer
value before you try and ask them for
money or ask them for value.
In return.
It's the same with sales.
You have to build rapport and really
establish a relationship,
but it's important with mentors as well
because a lot of times if you're
reaching out to find a mentor or you're
reaching out to a,
someone important in your industry,
they're fielding a lot of the same sort
of requests from other individuals who
want their time and want their expertise
and so you could stand out by looking to
offer value to them and actually being
proactive about what it is they're
working on.
A,
for example,
I've reached out to New York Times
bestselling authors right before they're
about to come out with another book and
so I know that they are looking for
introductions to press.
I know that they are really busy and so
anything I can do to help them advance
the book that they're working on or save
them time is really valuable to them.
And so I would think about,
uh,
you know,
always being a good person,
providing value upfront.
And then number three is being
intentional about who you're trying to
build relationships with.
That level of intentionality I think is
missing for a lot of us in today's Day
and age.
There's so much noise coming at us and
so many pings coming through our
smartphone,
uh,
but if you're looking to build a world
class network and do it in a short
amount of time,
then you have to be intentional about
what types of people you want in your
network,
who you want to learn from,
uh,
and how you're going to give yourself
access to different networks.
And so for me,
uh,
I like to spend as much time as possible
with people that are super connectors,
meaning they are well regarded in their
industry.
They have high integrity and they're
also in a hub or an access point to a
bunch of other people.
In their industry,
and so I know,
you know,
two or three Olympians and if I ever had
a reason to reach out to more Olympians,
I would go through those two or three
individuals,
but I was a good person and meeting
them,
I provided them value upfront and now
you know,
I have a friendship with them that
allows me access to a bunch of other
Olympians.
And same with the world of authors.
Same with a lot of fortune 500 c suite
executives.
I know they all know each other.
And so if you can build a relationship
with people who are super connectors,
they give you access to a lot of other
people in their network if and when you
need it.
And then if and when you can provide
value to people in their network and you
know,
along the way you've gotta make sure
you're a good person and keep your
reputation solid.
Uh,
so at a high level,
that's how I would go about thinking
about networking,
relationship building.